The idea that the benefit system
perpetuates misery is not something that
I'm a stranger to have everyday when I
knocked doors as has been highlighted in
areas where people are struggling,
are in work and are struggling,
they will point out their neighbors to
me about how they're wrong ends and she
never goes out to work and he doesn't go
out to work and the kids are in the
garden and that was always a perception
that there is somebody next door getting
something that you are not getting.
So I asked the people.
My response is always would you swap
places?
It's so easy for them.
You're going out to work their lives
really easy.
Would you go?
Would you swap places?
And the answer is all,
of course not.
So what makes you think those people
chose it?
Either.
What makes you think your life is is so
different to theirs that they chose
something completely different to you?
There are many reasons why people end up
with benefits and the lady in the
audience has highlighted one of them.
We should stop treating these people
like they are not like us because one
day they will.
We all of us will fall and need the
benefits system if we haven't already.